vor knapp einem jahr habe ich mir selbst
experimenten angefangen und seitdem jede
woche irgendwas komplett verrücktes
gemacht oder gelernt klavierspielen zwei
sprachen sprechen und eine app zu
entwickeln sind nur wenige der 20 dinge
die ich ungefähr im letzten jahr gelernt
habe und so habe ich mir ein bisschen
den ruf aufgebaut alles zu können jetzt
ist die frage kann nicht wirklich alles
oder habe ich schon wieder das meiste
vergessen wird er uns raus und
überprüfen alle fähigkeiten in der
umgekehrten reihenfolge in der sie
gelernt hat also mit dem aktuellsten
zuerst dieses video wird unterstützt von
blink ist
wir fangen an mit origami ich versuche
man ihn gar nicht
ich hab ne bombe ist heute ja
[Musik]
jetzt bin ich schon ziemlich weit jetzt
muss noch passieren
dass hier auch dank einer guten
installateurs folgt also ein kleiner
fehler habe ich drin aber tasten kranich
origami mit ein bisschen vorlage kann
ich also noch
der handstand ganze 44 sekunden habe ich
es in meinem video innerhalb von einer
woche geschafft den handstand zu
erhalten ich glaube es ja nicht was ich
das nochmal hinkriegt
[Musik]
alter voll krass ich bin dann auch noch
offen links hier
[Musik]
ich würde sagen 39 sekunden das kann man
stehen lassen oder
gaming bzw mal schauen wie gut ich noch
bin habe ich hier 64.000 240 punkte
erreicht
[Musik]
aber ganz knapp 50.000 machen müssen die
maus langsam
57.000 wir probieren sie noch mal
[Musik]
was 66 habe immer meine rekord von 4g /
ich würde sagen das kann ich noch
einfach zerstört
französisch aus malta so
fehlt es in dem appell zum arzt und
patient
ab
interessante
[Musik]
soll so dass wir jetzt tricky ich bin
mir ziemlich sicher dass ich kein kind
mehr kann weil ich hier noch nie konnte
aber ich kann mir vorstelle dass ich den
oli noch halbwegs kann und ja wir finden
dass ich meine wohnung aus tut mir leid
an die die unter um sowohl nachhaltig
mir selber
nicht so laut war es gar nicht
okay das war jetzt ein bisschen schul
oder sing mal auf dem teppich weiter
das ist voll okay das skateboardfahren
in der wohnung ist voll okay solange uns
auf teppich macht
ist jetzt nicht mehr schön aber ich
würde sagen kann man gelten lassen
javier hat mit am meisten spaß gemacht
und umso mehr spaß macht es auch das
rauszufinden ob ich das noch kann
[Musik]
da sag ich mal gucken
anderen
[Musik]
okay du bist noch mal fehlerfrei
med
[Musik]
ja ein bisschen holprig aber ich würde
sagen das kann man auch durch die lassen
wir doch sagen dass es besser ist als im
original video
[Applaus]
[Musik]
schlösser knacken hat sich als ein nicht
ganz so sicher skilled entpuppt wie ich
es mir vorgestellt habe im medio dazu
habe ich nur für zwei drei vier und fünf
geschafft und das hier sogar mit einer
büroklammer und das dmrz morgen schon
hinkriegt setzt den hier so rein selbst
den quasi unter drehung und trimet dann
mit dem links der ball nun setzt die
einzelnen teams einen nachbarn oder
runden
das war ungefähr zwei sekunden
wenn ich jetzt schafft das ding mit
einer büroklammer zu knacken lassen das
durchgehen also schlosses zu ich bin
jetzt hier mal einen niedrig und auch so
ein hebel sowie programme ist der in als
hebel jetzt mal schauen ob es eigentlich
pins wo du kriegst
du pin steckt
ich würde sagen wir mannschaft mit einer
büroklammer
das also dass das wasser durch geht auf
jeden fall
rückwärtssalto
wenn ich das jetzt machen würde würde
ich mir das genick brechen
nicht bestanden
online poker ja wie es innerhalb von
einer woche geschafft mit strategie und
ich zum glück aus 1000 dollar 1400
dollar zu machen mal schauen ob ich das
noch drauf habt also jesus einfach bei
allem raus zu gehen was nicht komplett
gutes beispiel nokia geht man nur mit
der geht immer hausherr
moment wieder immer haus das ist der
literally free money
das tut weh drei könige stanke für seine
fünf euro wird das noch mal machen er
macht das noch mal
und noch mal und in einer so weil der
ausgehen wird
ok hat also das als peinlich
[Musik]
er macht wollen wir mal schauen oder
let's go ich will ihnen spaß nicht
verderben es sieht aber schlecht hinaus
sieht es schlechter aus dass ich sie
richtig schlecht hinaus noch knapp 10
euro profit gemacht zweimal in folge
gewonnen und bevor man eine
glückssträhne cent will ich mal sagen
dass man durchgehend card rowing also
karten werfen ist es gelder nicht
tatsächlich aus ich halte nicht auf
meinem kanal sondern auf dem von marius
angeschrieben gelernt habe
man schon sagen kann dass wir manchmal
gefährlich
ich glaube die technik wieder raus das
ziel ist es natürlich ein zum stecken zu
bringen
ich würde sagen
das reicht uns auf jeden fall
zwei minuten 20 habe ich es auch auf
marios kanal aus gehalt in einem
wassertank wie diesem hier
luftanhalten netz gemacht
[Musik]
nur knapp einer minute die prüfen das
habe ich nicht verkaufen eine eigene app
entwickeln in diesem video ich
tatsächlich meinen penis gelb ins leben
gerufen die den epson place search als
platz eins und zwei gestürmt hat
mittlerweile hab ich dafür den richtigen
programmierer eingestellt mal schauen ob
ich auch noch selber eine app hinkriegt
neue
2d sowie das noch gleich mit dem dass
knöpfe sachen machen eine sekunde also
dass wir das richtig gilt aha jetzt
klappt das ja wild so natürlich zählen
hier nicht ausprobiert habe hier habe
ich jetzt endlich mal hier zum laufen
gebracht die app zeigt voll geil jetzt
nicht klicken felix wissen zu testen
wenn ich getroffen wollen
okay
das war's dieser sie verloren
ja und jeder der sagt dass keine
richtige app
hecken lernen hier habe ich doch
tatsächlich gelernt wie man einfache
wlan passwörter und ganze windows
passwörter komplett um geht ja aber das
zu wiederholen könnte ich jetzt nur wenn
ich eins zu eins ein tutorial nachahmer
also ich würde sagen das können wir
nicht durchgehen lassen dass das kann
ich nicht mehr
abitur in einer woche da ich mein
allgemeines abitur abgebrochen habe man
wolle herausfinden ob ich in einer woche
schafft da zu bestehen und das gerade
somit absolut schlechten 5 punkten
bestanden aufgabe 1 gegeben diese
funktionen dann zeigen sie dass für den
herrn der abt leitungsfunktion haar
spricht von h glaubt nicht dass ich das
machen wir hat bestimmen sie die
koordinaten des im zweiten quadranten
liegen denn ich spring mal zur nächsten
aufgabe die abbildung 1 zeigt den grafen
der fitnesstest des
sondereinsatzkommandos ksk schaffe ich
den noch angefangen wird mit klimmzügen
und zwar auf dem stück a
[Musik]
pendelt auf vier mal neun meter in unter
85 sekunden mal schauen ich habe mich
wahnsinnig viel platz aber ich konnte
mir hier neunmeter abstecken
10 sekunden 9 das ist ja lahm
knapp 14 sekunden hatte gerade so noch
gestanden aber nicht so gut 40 sekunden
später habe es minimum sind die 21 und
optimum 40 auf geht's tanner geht ab
jetzt
[Musik]
der muskelkater
okay bis hierhin nährt der roten karte
zu sehr eingeengt der test wird aber
nicht durch
spanische small talk mit sophie kann
lustig werden im jama thomas müller
thomas konnte amazon musik premier
[Gelächter]
tadeusz
zeichnen lernen in einer woche in diesem
video habe ich schon mal ein fortschritt
bisschen festzuhalten am anfang und am
ende jeweils ein flugzeug einen baum und
ein auge gezeichnet und das also das
flugzeug das sei jetzt auch siegen zum
flugzeug überhaupt aus verhinden
[Musik]
dann noch ein bisschen schattierungen
ran müssen mehr schatten und einen
turbinen generell schaden würde dir vor
abgedunkelt
so also besser wird's nicht ich finde
das ist aber ein hübsches flugzeug
eigentlich es ist aber nicht annähernd
so schön wie das flugzeug hat sich in
meinem video gemacht habe also würde ich
sagen durchgefallen und
spinning hier ist unser nächstes gilt
wenn man das so nennen darf und ich
hoffe ich mache mein handy jetzt nicht
final komplett kaputt es ist generell
schwierig das überhaupt irgendwie lang
zu machen
aber so eine ganze sekunde ist
eigentlich schon im presse
also besser jetzt nicht
augen unabhängig voneinander bewegen
lernen wir probieren es mal
[Musik]
dass vielleicht ein bisschen den augen
und ich muss mich übel konzentrieren ich
hab mir hat die aufnahme angeschaut das
10 ja mal sowas von objekten konnten
schlafen lernen in einer minute mein
absolut allererstes selbstexperiment auf
diesem kanal und für heute auch das
letzte mit skurrilen atemtechnik habe
ich es geschafft innerhalb von einer
minute ungefähr einzuschlafen mal
schauen ob das noch so läuft
[Musik]
wie ich bin zwar bemüht aber
das wird nicht nur 11 von den 20
fähigkeiten nicht im letzten jahr
gelernt habe sitzen also noch aktuell
läuft das buch atome credits oder zu
deutsch die ein prozent methode in dem
es darum geht wie man auch im jahre 2021
neue gewohnheiten endlich beherzt sich
dadurch jeden tag fast automatisch ein
kleines stückchen verbessert und damit
langfristig großes schafft mit blink ist
dem sponsor des heutigen videos schafft
erst auf jeden fall das konsumieren von
büchern wie diesen zur gewohnheit zu
machen linke ist komprimiert die
wichtigsten inhalte eines buches auf
circa 15 minuten höher oder lesedauer
das ist extrem wertvoll um unfassbar
schnell da informationen reinzukriegen
unter anderem eine detaillierte
anleitung wie man sich gute gewohnheiten
angewöhnt zum beispiel sport lernen und
gesunde ernährung und wie man sich
negative gewohnheiten abgewöhnen den
link zum buch etwa mails bzw die ein
prozent methode findet ihr in deutsch
und in englisch auf blinkt ist genau wie
tausende anderer bücher zu den themen
wissenschaft psychologie unternehmertum
persönlichkeitsentwicklung und viel mehr
bombardiert euch jetzt eine woche
kostenlos mit dem wissen dass euch im
leben oder im beruf weiterhilft
aufblinkt de / tommy eine davon
überzeugt zeit erhalte der 20 prozent
auf das jahres-abo blinkt ist premium
erster link in der infobox blinkt ist
punkt de / tommy und damit bin ich mal
gespannt was wir dieses jahr so
einstellen 2021 ist noch lang und wir
werden mit sicherheit einige neue
gewohnheiten reinkommen aber dass ich
auch ein haufen neuer fähigkeiten wenn
ihr darauf lust habt abonniert gerne
diesen kanal und dann sehen wir zunächst
mal wieder macht's gut
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja